bonjour et bienvenue dans Europe Hebdo
au Parlement européen ici à Bruxelles et
focus dans cette émission sur Erasmus
qui a bien failli disparaître nous irons
en Angleterre à la rencontre d'étudiants
qui suivent ce programme emblématique de
l'Europe mais tout de suite l'actualité
avec cette question l'Europe de la
défense existe-t-elle nous recevons le
général Patrick de Rousier il est le
président du Comité militaire de l'Union
européenne une question qui se pose
après l'intervention de la francealie
Nora
Mad après quelques semaines de combat
les militaires français et maliens ont
repris Gao puis tombouou l'objectif
désormais consolider les positions et
permettre le déploiement des troupes
africaines 5000 hommes en provenance du
Tchad du Niger du Sénégal ou encore du
Burkina et l'Europe que fait l'Europe ah
oui l'Union va déployer la mission euutm
au Mali une mission de formation prévue
depuis des mois mais rester dans les
cartons elle ne sera déployée finalement
qu'à partir de mi-février un peu tard
non du côté de la France si les belles
paroles de soutien sont nombreuses
l'appui effectif c'est plutôt du bout
des lèvres non quelques avions
ravitailleurs quelques livraisons
d'armes et de munition quelques R
quelques hommes mais pas de combattants
un peu court alors la France est-elle
seule au
Mali alors pour répondre à cette
question nous sommes avec le général
Patrick de Rousier bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes le président du Comité
militaire de l'Union européenne vous
êtes de nationalité française mais
aujourd'hui c'est avec la casquette
européenne que vous allez nous parler et
c'est la première fois que vous donnez
une interview à la télévision depuis que
vous avez été nommé en fin d'année 2012
donc merci d'accorder la primeure aux
chaînes parlementaires français merci à
vous pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas donc au
Mali des soldats des combattant avec sur
l'épaule le drapeau européen
permettez-moi d'abord de préciser mon
rôle en tant que président du Comité
militaire président du Comité militaire
c'est le porte-parole des chefs
d'état-major des armées des 27 chefs
d'état-major des armées c'est le
conseiller militaire de Madame Ashton et
de l'ensemble de la structure du service
européen d'action extérieure madame
Ashton donc qui est la Haute
Représentante le ministre des Affaires
étrangères de l'Europe tout à fait et
puis c'est la la personne qui doit aider
à bâtir du consensus parce que un
engagement européen c'est un engagement
solidaire de l'ensemble des 27 et donc
c'est créer les processus les
discussions les échanges qui vont
permettre au 27 de se forger
collectivement une idée et de s'engager
dans le cadre du Mali l'Europe l'Europe
de la défense est active est active
depuis longtemps et s'engage s'engage
avec détermination au côté du Mali au
côté des forces africaines qui vont
s'engager et bien sûr au côté de la
France mais vous dites elle s'engage
activement mais il y a des soutiens
logistiqu une dizaine de pays qui ont
apporté par exemple des des avions ou
des moyens logistiques mais la France
est seule à se battre ceux qui prennent
des risques ceux qui peuvent mourir ce
sont des soldats français comment on
peut expliquer
ça c'est une décision de la France de
s'engager qui a été salué par l'ensemble
des pays européens lors d'un dernier
conseil avec les ministres des Affaires
étrangères c'est la France et le Mali
qui est au au combat pour récupérer
l'intégrité territoriale du Mali mais
c'est accompagné par une solidarité et
une inscription dans la durée et c'est
cette inscription dans la durée qui est
très importante au plan européen qui est
un signe fort d'engagement et qui est
important pour la stabilité du Sahel
dans son ensemble puisqu'il s'agit de
développer tous les outils qui sont les
outils qui vont permettre à la force
africaine de se déployer c'est pour ça
qu'il y a eu une Clearing House une
structure d'échange permettant de savoir
quels étaient les besoins des pays
africains en terme d'équipement en terme
de transport pour pouvoir aller au Mali
et puis c'est l'aide aussi bien sûr que
l'on peut apporter à titre bilatéral
mais ceci était le fruit d'une prise de
conscience collective qui a été forgé
bien sûr dans les dialogues bilatéraux
entre Paris et les capitales mais aussi
ici à Bruxelles dans les instances que
ce soit au comité milire ou que ce soit
dans les réunions avec les ambassadeurs
pour montrer l'importance de cette zone
et l'importance pour l'Europe alors si
l'Europe fait autant de chose que que
que vous le dites aujourd'hui évidemment
on veut bien vous croire mais comment se
fait-il qu'il y ait par exemple en
France cette cette polémique qui ne
cesse pas depuis maintenant 15 jours
depuis le début des frappes françaises
sur le
Mali sur justement cette absence
européenne comment vous expliquez ça
vous je crois que c'est peut-être un
défaut pour de notre part nous Européens
et merci de donner l'occasion de
d'illustrer ce qui se fait parce qu'on
on peut-être ne communiqueon pas assez
pour faire permettre à chacun de
percevoir ses engagements l'Europe est
engagée depuis longtemps au Mali en
terme de développement en terme d'aide
humanitaire elle a défini récemment une
stratégie pour le Sahel elle a
maintenant la décision de s'engager pour
une mission iutm Mali longue de
formation de la nouvelle armée malienne
une armée qui doit être sous l'autorité
bien évidemment du gouvernement civil et
qui doit s'inscrire dans le cadre des
règles internationales d'engagement
vis-à-vis d'une population c'est ce qui
va se bâtir progressivement et c'est
pour ça que cet engagement européen est
important il est important parce qu'il
s'inscrit dans la durée sur 15 mois pour
ce qui est du volet militaire alors vous
avez parlé de cette cette mission donc
iutm donc en fait c'est une formation
une mission européenne de de formation
qui est d'ailleurs dirigé par un un
général un autre général français le
général le Cointre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des détails déjà
est-ce que par exemple on connaît les
dates précises de de mise sur pied de
cette formation au Mali la décision de
lancement de cette mission devrait être
prise au milieu du mois de février vers
le 12 février donc très prochainement en
fait avec dès le début dès cette ate là
la première partie de des actions qui
seront menées auprès du Mali mais
parallèlement à ça il y a tout le reste
des activités qui sont menées par
l'Union européenne il y a en ce moment à
bamaco une délégation de l'Union
européenne avec à la fois la Commission
et le service européen d'action
extérieur pour identifier quelles sont
les évolutions dans les actions qui sont
menées en terme de développement en
terme de d'utilisation de la facilité de
la paix pour l'Afrique un certain nombre
de contributions qui vont permettre
d'aider à la stabilisation de la
situation non pas au plan militaire mais
au plan du développement parce que la la
question se pose effectivement de savoir
s'il fallait se remettre comme c'était
le cas auparavant et ça avait été arrêté
à aider financièrement ce pays tout à
fait après le coup d' état et il y a eu
la décision par l'Union européenne
d'arrêter l'ensemble des investissements
qui étaient effectués d'abord pour créer
une pour analyser aussi pour créer une
pression vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
population et mais surtout du
gouvernement et puis pour qu'il y ait
une feuille de route cette feuille de
route du gouvernement a été est en cours
de finalisation et va permettre un
investissement beaucoup plus important
et et dans la durée dans tous les
secteurs puisqu'il s'agit de restaurer
un état de droit dans un pays qui a été
profondément bouleversé ces derniers
temps et c'est ce que l'on fait un peu
partout l'Union européenne fait ça bien
sûr au Mali et c'est ce qui est au cœur
de l'activité de l'actualité en tout cas
de chacun mais c'est le cas aussi dans
la cor de l'Afrique et la corord de
l'Afrique est illustratif aussi de ce
que l'Union européenne peut apporter ça
n'est pas que le volet militaire mais il
y a aussi tous les autres volets une
question quand même sur le volet
militaire il existe ce qu'on appelle
dans un bon français les battle group
battle group en fait un un groupe de de
2000 hommes je crois un groupe européens
de 2000 hommes qui normalement devrait
pouvoir intervenir sur des des terrains
d'action ex exérieur ce qui ce qui
aurait pu être le cas à au Mali ça s pas
fait en fait ce ce groupe n'est jamais
intervenu est-ce que vous pensez qu'il a
encore une utilité les cant tactiqu ont
une utilité ils ont une utilité parce
que c'est d'abord la démonstration d'une
volonté des pays européens d'avoir en
permanence en alerte à quelques jours
une capacité permettant de déployer dans
tous les casadres so n'interviennent
jamais parce qu' il faut il faut
l'unanimité des 27 pour que pour qu'ils
interviennne donc c'est souvent un peu
long le le cadre bien évidemment est
celui de l'unanimité c'est ou court
selon les situations il se trouve qu'au
Mali ça n'était pas approprié ça n'était
pas approprié parce que l'engagement a
été un engagement d'une nation qui a
conduit dans les premières heures avec
une réactivité qui devait être immédiate
cette réactivité bien sûr immédiate elle
ne peut pas être apportée par n'importe
quelle organisation quelle qu'elle soit
multinationale et donc l'Union
européenne aurait pu intervenir si les
événements avaient été différents avec
son groupement tactique bien évidemment
l'analyse a été qui effectué ici à
Bruxelles ça n'était ni une demande du
Mali ni une demande de la France et donc
ça n'était pas ce qui a été envisagé
mais ça ne veut pas dire que ce n'est
pas utile parce que outre les volets que
je venais d'évoquer il y a aussi
l'interopérabilité entre les forces
européennes qui est très utile puisque
c'est ce développement des groupement
tactiques qui leur permet de mieux se
connaître à la fois sur le terrain les
soldats mais aussi dans les structures
décisionnell alors je voudrais vous
poser une dernière question et si c'est
possible j'aimerais que vous puissiez me
donner une une réponse synthétique
est-ce que vous vous pensez
que l'Europe de la défense dont on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui existe j'ai envie
de dire tout de même l'Europe de la
défense existe le service Europ nation
extérieur est actif des cellules de
crise réunissent très régulièrement pour
analyser les enjeux pour définir des
objectifs pour ensuite pouvoir discuter
entre ambassadeurs au Comité militaire
d'options de telle sorte à ce que
collectivement les 27 décident des
actions qui peuvent être menées et bien
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation Patrick de Rousier d'avoir
apporté des éclaircissements sur cette
Europe de la défense l'Europe qui se
demande aujourd'hui si elle va continuer
avec ou sans la Grande-Bretagne vous
savez que David Cameron a récemment fait
un discours dans lequel il évoque un
référendum sur la sortie de son pays de
l'Union européenne alors nous avons
voulu savoir avec Aurélie dafas ce qu'en
pensaient les télévisions européennes et
ensuite nous reviendrons avec un invité
un confrère britannique
regardez l'Union construira-elle demain
sans les Britanniques la question
inquiète l'Europe et divise le
Royaume-Uni l'opposition attaque David
Cameron pourquoi ne peut-il pas dire de
façon claire qu'il votera oui au
référendum parce qu'il a peur des gens
qui sont assis derrière lui la seule
chose qui a changé par rapport à il y a
quelques mois lorsqu'il s'était prononcé
contre un référendum ce n'est pas la
situation en Europe mais la situation au
sein du Parti conservateur pourquoi ne
l'admet-il pas sa conduite est dictée
non par l'intérê national mais par son
parti David Cameron réf toute position
isolationniste mais sur les télévisions
européenne l'atmosphère est au
pessimisme David Cameron s'est engagé de
tout son cœur à défendre le maintien du
Royaume-Uni dans l'Union européenne mais
si les citoyens de ce pays décident de
sortir ils auront pris une décision
irréversible comme l'a dit Cameron ce
sera comme acheter un allé simple sans
retour all simple une solution perdant
perdant pour RTBF avec des conséquences
financières aujourd'hui la City joue sur
deux plans elle joue sur le premier plan
qui est sa valeur internationale et sur
le deuxième plan qui est sa valeur de
faire partie du marché unique si demain
on lui retirait sa deuxième sa deuxème
valeur ajoutée de faire partie du marché
unique il n'est pas certain qu'elle
conserverait sa première valeur ajoutée
d'être une d'être une place financière
internationale et la Grande-Bretagne ne
serait pas la seule perdante une Union
européenne sans les Britanniques risque
aussi d'être
affaibli alors comme promis nous avons
été rejoint par Charles Bremner bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes rédacteur en
chef Europe le correspondant ici à
Bruxelles du Times j'ai envie de dire
une question personnelle pour commencer
depuis le discours de David Cameron il y
a maintenant quelques jours est-ce que
vous en tant que britannique vous êtes
perçu un peu différemment ici à
Bruxelles pas vraiment parce que les les
Britanniques ont toujours été les
mauvais élèves le mauvais élève de
l'Union européenne comme vous savez il y
a un peu de fatigue sur la question la
question britannique va maintenant pas
dominer mais va très présent pendant des
années à venir est-ce que vous diriez en
ce qui concerne David Cameron que ce
qu'il a fait là c'est de l'électoralisme
ou est-ce qu'il y a réellement est-ce
que nous les autres Européens on doit
s'attendre à la sortie du Royaume-Uni de
de de de l'Union européenne il y a des
deux il y a de l'électoralisme plutôt
des problèmes intern du parti par
conservateur depuis 30 ans maintenant le
Parti conservateur est divisé par la
question de l'Europe ce n'est pas
vraiment une question qui excite obsède
les Britanniques en général mais c'est
vrai qu'il a une europhobie en général
et David Cameron essaie aussi de lancer
l'absè Europe pour pour tout le pays
est-ce que cette europhobie est en train
d'augmenter certainement oui depuis la
crise de l'euro l'europhobie est passé
en euroscepticisme passé en majorité au
moins 5 % du pays alors avant d'être en
poste ici à Bruxelles vous avez fait de
nombreuses capitales dont des capitales
européennes et dont Paris est-ce que
vous diriez que il y a les mêmes
reproches qui sont faits à l'Europe de
de Bruxelles à Londres qu'à Paris est-ce
que c'est la même chose ce n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose même le
contraire en France c'est c'est très
amusant j'arrive je n'arrive pas à
convaincre mes collègues à Londres que
en France l'Union européenne est vu
comme l'otage des Anglo-Saxons avec le
libéralisme le marché libre et tout ça
privatisation parce que pour la
Grande-Bretagne l'Union européenne c'est
une construction française pour dominer
l'Europe et vous pensez également que
cet
euroscepticisme est en train de monter
sur le sur le continent européen
certainement pour pour les un peu les
mêmes raisons c'est-à-dire l'idée que
Bruxelles est n'est pas démocratique on
ne sait pas comment prendre les
décisions qu'il se mêle de tout et que
c'est une chose un peu étrangère
dernière question vous pensez que vous
l'avez un peu dit d'ailleurs dans votre
précédente réponse mais que
finalement l'Union européenne va
maintenant se tourner vers vers la
Grande-Bretagne c'estàd dans les années
qui viennent est-ce qu'on est en train
d'entrer dans une période de turbulence
politique après une période de
turbulence économique oui je crois que
les deux sont liés la turbulence
économique de l'euro est directement
liée avec la situation britannique si
l'euro se ressuscite les Anglais vont
devenir moins moins hostiles je pense
merci beaucoup Charles Bremner d'avoir
accepté notre invitation nous allons
parler maintenant d'Erasmus Erasmus qui
est un programme qui a 25 ans qui est
sûrement le programme européen le plus
populaire chez les jeunes et un
programme qui a eu des difficultés de
financement nous allons maintenant
parler avec Katia Gilder et son invité
d'érasmus mais tout de suite reportage à
Londres signé Paul
Bouffard
au milieu des flocons de neige Tangui 23
ans loin de sa région lyonaise le
frenchy s'est lancé dans des études à
l'étranger en marketing international
ici sur le campus de l'université
anglaise de riding à quelques minutes de
Londres donc aujourd'hui travailler et
découvrir ce que c'est que la vie
eraspus ça apporte beaucoup de choses
notamment une première expérience
internationale ça permet aussi de
découvrir de nouvelles culture de
s'adapter à un nou un nouvel
environnement et puis bah ça permet
aussi une certaine ouverture d'esprit
qui est un prérequis actuellement dans
dans dans le monde du travail de toute
façon une expérience internationale est
forcément un avantage sur le CV Erasmus
une success story d'un quart de siècle
le programme d'échange éducatif a fait
ses preuves il permet au étudiants
européens de faire une partie de leur
cursus universitaire à
l'étranger près de 3 millions de jeunes
en ont bénéficié un système qui a fait
de la mobilité étudiante le trait
d'union entre pays de l'Union européenne
en 1987 l'objectif était d'éveiller
l'identité citoyenne du Vieux Continent
et parole de professeur ça marche encore
depuis 15 ans Françoise Lau enseigne à
l'université de Reading l'intérêt est
toujours aussi vivace et du point de vue
d'une enseignant dans une section de
langue moderne je dirais même que le
programme Erasmus est est devenu
absolument essentiel ce sont des
étudiants qui vont être assidu ce sont
des étudiants qui vont être
enthousiastes qui vont s'exprimer
beaucoup en classe dans les discussions
et dans les débats et qui vont apporter
un point de vue légèrement différent qui
est aussi extrêmement enrichissant pour
les étudiants locaux pourtant ces
dernières semaines à cours d'argent
l'Union européenne a voulu couper dans
le budget du programme collatéral de la
crise et bien non les instances
européennes reviennent sur la décision
et proposent même d'augmenter de 70 % le
budget sur la période 2014 à 2020 je
crois que les fonctionnaires de
Bruxelles n'ont strictement aucune
crainte à avir c'est un c'est un système
qui qui a de beaux jours devant lui
simplement parce que c'est un système
qui s'est rendu absolument
indispensable
le Royaume-Uni une terre où
l'euroscepticisme n'est plus légende et
pourtant ici le programme est en pleine
progression même si les chiffres ne sont
pas de l'Espagne ou de la France au BRC
organisation gouvernementale pour
l'éducation on est loin d'abandonner
Erasmus on ESTs content de voir une
augmentation du nombre d'étudis C
dernières années
depuis prramme on a noté une Haus de 8%
par an du nombre d'étudiants pour
l'année passée nous avons eu plus de
13000 jeunes Erasmus c'est un record
pour le 25e anniversaire du programme
preuve que ça marche
bien clairement sil veulent travailler
dans un autre pays européen c'est un
plus pour eu car ils ont une ouverture
d'esprit mais même s'il rest ici au
Royaume-Uni les employeurs disent que
ces étudiants sont plus matures ils ont
plus de choses à offrir qu'un étudiant
qui est resté chez
lui salut bien la maison
Tangi V en colocation avec d'autres
étudiants étrangers pour eu cette
réussite coûte cher être étudiant
Erasmus n'est aujourd'hui plus donné à
tout le monde certains parlent même d'un
système réserv à des étudiants favorisés
alors pour êreudasmus il faut avoir
quelques quelques sous de côté parce que
bourseasmus ne suffit pas bien
s les bourses ça c'est mes parents qui
financent alors moi le montant de ma
bourse il s'élève à 1500 € à peu près
pour les 9 mois où j'étudie en Erasmus
Bora étudiant espagnol de 25 ans voit
dans ce programme une solution pour
trouver du travail en Espagne un jeune
sur deux est au chômage alors lui il
pense rester en
Angleterre en Espagne aujourd'hui c'est
pratiquement impossible de trouver un
travail en Angleterre ça me semble plus
facile j'aurais plus de possibilités
ici premièrement mon anglais s'est
amélioré vraiment et
ensuite avoir un diplôme validé à
l'étranger c'est c'est plus valorisant
que dans son propre
pays alors Erasmus une solution à la
crise une chose est sû le programme
estcrit patrimoine européen en 2011
230000 étudiants ont bénéficié d'Erasmus
désormais chaque année l'objectif sera
de permettre à 700000 nouveaux jeunes
d'étudier à
l'étranger reportage sous la neige de
Reading en Grande-Bretagne signé Paul
Bouffard et nous accueillons Doris PAC
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européenne venu d'Allemagne et vous
présidez la commission culture et
éducation vous êtes battu pour
qu'Erasmus survivere alors le
financement est assuré pour l'année qui
vient mais jusqu'à jusqu'à quand
ouis cette fois-ci on on discute le
programme qui existe encore c'est-à-dire
c'est fini à la fin desannées 13 et on
va recommencer avec un nouveau programme
comme avec tous les programmes Fonds
Social fonds structurel agriculture tout
ça on va
commencer 2014 jusqu'au 2020 et est-ce
que aujourd'hui il y a de l'argent pour
Erasmus oui on a on a décidé il y a 8
ans il a 7 ans qu'on aura assez d'argent
malheureusement on a on a une habitude
de gérer les budgets c'est difficile à
faire comprendre aux gens je n'arrête je
commence pas donc en tout cas on a de
l'argent ce n'est pas Erasmus qui va
souffrir et Erasmus ce n'est pas
seulement Erasmus c'est éducation dès
dès la premère jusqu'au jusqu'au même la
fin de la vie parce qu'on a quatre
programmes dedans pour les jeunes c'est
le Comenius pour les pux qui font
l'apprentissage c'est Leonardo pour les
étudiants c'est Erasmus et pour lifelong
learning c'est grandvich bon mais
maintenant vous le savez quel est quel
est quel est pour vous le premier
intérêt de tous ces programmes bah alors
de faire connaître l'Europe et l'idée de
l'Europe aux jeunes parce qu'ils sont
nés dans une Union européenne et qui
connaissent pas l'origine et surtout le
devoirs de soutenir et de faire vivre
cette Europe alors depuis Berlin
François Hollande et Angela Merkel ont
proposé d'élargir le champ de d'érasmus
ils ont dit en tout cas Angela Merkel
elle dit il faut que les ouvriers
puissent aussi apprendre une langue
étrangère est-ce qu'il faut élargir
Erasmus en faire un Erasmus pour tous
Alors moi j'étais préson à Berlin je
peux dire j'étais très contente moi j'ai
applaudi j'ai commencé à applaudir parce
que tous les deux on parlait d'éducation
il faut pas élargir parce que on a déjà
élargi depuis 20 ans c'estàdire tout ça
existe mais ce n'est pas assez utilisé
et c'est plus que normal que des jeunes
ouvriers parlent une langue étrangère
moi j'habite en Sare c'est-à-dire les
gens de la Lorine ou les gens de la Sare
ils doivent parler la la langue du
voisin parce qu'autrement le le le le
marché interne le petit dans la grande
région SAR leur luxe n'est pas utilisé
n'est pas à utiliser donc il faut leur
donner la chance de vraiment travailler
à travers vers les frontières qui
n'existent plus mais pas dans le cadre
d'Erasmus vous dites Erasmus c'est
réservé pour les étudiants c'est ça vous
dites oui mais pour beaucoup de gens
Erasmus c'est un synonyme pour mobilité
mais Erasmus c'est vraiment pour les
étudiants Leonardo était déjà depuis 20
ans pour des ouvriers ou pour des jeunes
qui qui vont devenir un un ouvrier donc
on a aussi des un programme pour les
pour des écolier coménus ça ça va
vraiment très bien et moi je voudrais
vraiment que qu'on qu'on s'occupe plus
de ces programmes parce que ça c'est
vraiment le ferment de notre travail en
Europe est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
sont assez connus et qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez faire ici en tant que député
européenne pour pour M faire connaître
du grand public éout nous on travaille
mais on a besoin de vous pour pour faire
diffuser tout ce que nous faisons alors
Erasmus est connu mais il faut faire
connaître aussi comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure à vous on a un programme de
jeunesse pour les volontaires moi j'ai
rencontré son volontaire allemand qui
étit l'année dernière euh n'importe où
en EUR qu'il qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
travaillent dans un environnement
culture ou ou ou santé ou environnement
ou bon ou éducation il cherchent ca la
commission aide et donc à la fin de 12
mois ou même 6 mois ils ont vraiment eu
une connaissance de l'Europe
extraordinaire est-ce que ce type de de
programme peut aussi permettre à ces
jeunes de mieux s'insérer plus tard dans
le marché du travail travail alors que
le chaage des jeunes est quand même une
préoccupation naturellement si vous êtes
dans un dans un dans un environnement
étranger vous vous entendez une autre
langue vous essayez de la comprendre ou
de la parler donc je pense c'est c'est
vraiment une aide essentielle pour la
comment dirais-je la globalisation de
notre monde donc alors il faut vraiment
que qu'on donne toutes les chances et et
des gens connaissent ces chances là et
c'est à travers des médias on peut le
faire connaître alors il y a une idée
qui circule sur le financement de ces
programmes il y en a certains qui
proposent de d'affecter le produit de la
future taxe sur les transactions
financières à Erasmus qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez je rien contre vous savez si
on compare le le le monnaie le budget
qui est prévu pour l'éducation ensemble
pas seulement Erasmus pour les étudiant
mais pour tout pour toute l'éducation
toute l'éducation alors c'est je veux
dire en anglais imp pinal
mais si on augmente ce peinut ce n'est
pas beaucoup mais 60 pres ça représente
combien du Budet c'est 1 % 1,5 % donc
alors ce n'est rien donc alors si on
augmente comme on a prévu comme la
Commission a prévu le Parlement en 70 %
ce n'est même pas beaucoup mais c'est
beaucoup pour l'intérêt d'éducation ce
pin qui peut faire beaucoup comme vous
ou c'est ça et bien merci Doris PAC
d'avoir été notre invité interview
express puis que vous devez revenir dans
l'émicycle merci et à bientôt c'est la
fin de cette émission on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec Nora Amadi à
Strasbourg très bonne suite de programme
sur les chaînes
parlementaires